[Musique]
ses cheveux sont dorés creux
ses lèvres douce
surprise ses mains ne sont jamais
froides elle s'est améliorée Davis je vais
les mettre de la musique sur
toi tu n'auras pas à y réfléchir à
deux fois elle est pure comme la neige de New York
elle a parié
Davis et elle le fera  elle te taquinera
d'autant mieux juste pour te plaire
elle est
précoce et elle sait exactement ce qu'il faut
pour faire rougir un pro elle a gr une
taille Garo stand-off elle a Betty
[Musique]
Daze elle t'a laissé l'emporter à la
maison  w un
appétit, elle était allongée sur un
trône, elle a eu BTY Davide, elle va te
tomber dessus
Royal comme si tu étais un
dé jusqu'à ce que tu deviennes
bleu, elle a eu une meilleure
taille D, elle t'exposera quand elle te fera
tomber de la neige avec le Crum elle
te jette, elle est
précoce et elle sait exactement ce qu'il
faut pour le faire
rougir Ro tous les garçons qui pensent qu'elle est une
espionne, elle a parié d
[Musique]
SI et elle te taquinera, elle t'inquiétera
mieux juste pour te faire plaisir, elle est
précoce  et elle sait exactement ce qu'il
faut pour faire
rougir tous les garçons, ils pensent qu'elle est une
espionne, elle a Betty Davis
[Musique]
SI [
Musique]
et elle te taquinera [
Musique],
elle te fera rire
[Musique]
juste pour  s'il
te plaît, elle a eu une meilleure journée
en plus, elle t'exposera
[Musique]
quand elle
te neige parce qu'elle sait ouais, elle a beaucoup d'
yeux Davis [Musique]